today alone that when you're visiting
the city by the bay you may want to
avoid spending too much time in the
Tenderloin I'm reto Meier Google
developer advocate join me today as I
investigate the San Francisco Police
Department
incidents public data set to discover
how crime is distributed around the city
without the danger of having to go
outside with bigquery did you create a
heat map like this one show any density
of SFPD incidents in San Francisco since
2010 the Tenderloin district really
stands out as a place we probably want
to avoid we can investigate further by
querying for areas with a high
concentration of a particular crime by
calculating the standard deviation of
both the latitude and longitude for each
type of crime we can find which crimes
have the greatest concentration in a
particular area and where those areas
are from this table we can see that drug
crime is the most concentrated in total
75% of the drug-related crimes in the
categories from the previous table
occurred in this part of San Francisco
the red boundary here indicates the
Tenderloin district we also learned that
prostitution arrests are highly
concentrated in this case they're split
between two separate but distinct areas
now by going in Reverse we get this
table showing us the most highly
distributed crimes crimes that occur
with similar frequencies all over the
city
notice that burglary theft and sound
property make up seven of the top ten
this map shows locations with at least
one burglary or attempted break-in in
terms of residential break-ins
seventy-four percent are the only
break-in recorded at that particular
location
this map shows only locations with five
or more burglary break-ins in terms of
personal safety
it's the areas where there's lots of
tourists and shoppers where you're most
likely to get mugged or pickpocketed
while in the city as shown in this heat
map bigquery includes many more public
datasets for San Francisco as well as
other cities including New York and
Chicago
what can you discover about the city's
living with bigquery your first terabyte
of processing and ten gigabytes of
storage each month is free get a
bigquery today and create your own San
Francisco and crime statistic
visualizations and share them with us
and of course subscribe to our Channel
and follow our blog to learn something
new with bigquery
[Music]